gaza affiche clairement ses couleurs le
vert symbole de l'islam bannières du
hamas
[Musique]
à chaque rond-point son monument dédié
aux martyrs au héros de la lutte armée
contre israël considéré comme un groupe
terroriste par beaucoup de pays dont le
canada
le hamas se présente ici comme un
mouvement de résistance
et comme parti politique qui règne sans
partage sur gaza au terme du dernier
affrontement avec israël son chef
apparaît triomphant et justifie la
guerre avec l'état hébreu la résistance
palestinienne n'avait pas le choix à
traduire en action son avertissement dit
il pour envoyer un message clair à
l'occupant
un conflit qui a cependant des
conséquences à gaza les vestiges de la
guerre sont omniprésents rappel du lourd
tribut payé ici par des populations
civiles prises entre deux feux
man source smile à beaugas jean par
exemple a tout perdu dans le
bombardement de sa maison un jour avant
la fin du ramadan ses yeux le hamas
était intouchable le seul responsable de
son malheur selon lui c'est israël-gaza
l'emprise du hamas est totale depuis une
quinzaine d'années ce qui est nouveau
c'est l' influence grandissante de ce
mouvement ailleurs palestine comme ici à
ramallah pourtant chasse gardée
traditionnellement du fatah le parti
historique
tsr arafat signe le plus visible du
changement des drapeaux verts ont
commencé à apparaître en cisjordanie est
de plus en plus de palestiniens vivent
ici affiche ouvertement leurs sympathies
surtout des jeunes
khadr et nathalie tous deux étudiants à
ramasser tenu debout pour nous dit il
c'est la première fois qu'on voit une
autorité en palestine qui défend sa
population et av
et si nathalie ne se dit pas tout
islamistes elle n'écarte pas la
possibilité de voter un jour le
développement logique selon ce
politologue
car le ramasser positionner exprès
défenseur de jérusalem pour faire de
l'ombre à l'autorité palestinienne
le viol est un crime hors du ring
confrontation selon lui si la popularité
du hamas était prévisible car il se
répète chaque conflit
elle est aussi généralement de courte
durée effects peu de chances donc
d'après lui il ramasse ne s'installe au
pouvoir
ailleurs qu'à gaza de toute façon il
n'ya pas d'élection à l'horizon les
dernières organise en palestine remonte
à 2006
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
ramallah